[Music]
what advice do you have for choosing
recommenders I don't know if applicants
really appreciate how important the
letters of reference are it's really the
one opportunity that we get to see you
through someone else's eyes objectively
what did you do and how did you do it so
for me it put a lot of emphasis on
making the selection I can give you some
tips and how to think about it at
Stanford we request two and one we asked
for a current direct supervisor or an
alternative you know the best
alternative if that is impossible or
inappropriate and then for the second
recommendation we also ask for someone
who supervised your work but it could be
from a non-profit it could be
extracurricular or from the same
organization now when you think about
selecting them we really just as I've
asked applicants and their essays to
tell us about the impact that they've
had because this past behavior will
predict future behavior that's the echo
that we want to see in the reference so
find someone who knows what you've done
you know really been in the trenches and
can see your work and describe not just
what happened but how you did it and how
the way you did it might have been
different from others so that means
don't worry about the title of a person
don't try to get the highest title also
I hear a lot of students asking or
applicants asking should I try to find
someone who went to Stanford because
that's important no it's not it's
actually what what the what the
recommender can tell us about you that
is most important the second thing is
after them understanding what you've
done is enthusiasm this is you know for
someone who reads lots of thousands of
recommendations this one's a hard one to
wrap your hands around but I know the
best recommendations that I read are
written from both a head space and a
heart space right so try to think about
who you've established a relationship
with someone who really
soozee Azam's a great word but has a
connection with you and will be able to
speak to that and that's how
recommendations become most memorable
and then lastly I think applicants
should think about the process don't ask
for recommendation and in email you know
it's a big it's gonna take this person a
significant amount of time on average
our references are about two pages I'm
guessing people have to spend at least
an hour to to do a good job on them
what's what is most disappointing to me
when I'm really looking to find
to admit is I'll get to the end of an
application I'll be on the second
recommendation I'll see someone
everything's been so positive and
they'll write a positive recommendation
but maybe only two paragraphs and just
say they're phenomenal they're the best
ever they've done a great job but I
won't have any of that data to help me
make a decision and it just means that
this particular applicant doesn't have
as much data I guess is the best word
but landscape for me to really
understand what they've done and how
they've done it so take it seriously
make an appointment even if it's a 15
minute chat but ask the question
courageously and say will you write it
it's important why where you're going
what schools didn't say do you have time
to invest to do a good job on this and
if someone says they're really busy
that's a good indication that maybe you
should go to your second choice because
it can make a difference in the end of
how much they're willing to spend time
to help you in this process and then for
the recommenders are there any resources
for them or how do they know how to
write them they're asking the best
question we try to give and many
recommenders have written more than one
before but we try to give them clear
advice and tips Wynnum they're invited
onto our portal on the website the
questions will ask how has this person
differentiated themselves from others
that they've seen I'm doing similar
roles and what have they done and
accomplished so they'll get that and I
think it's a it comes down to that
they're willing to take the time to
really support you you know there's no
magic there but they do have to make
that investment be close enough to you
to be able to write thoughtfully about
what you've done